Simmons with a woman he gets it this  pulls out by Amir Johnson  this one's their primary ball handler  fires away and fills it up from 653 to  35 billion this was a Joe's 35th season  Simmons's in Tulane keep track of that  with Joe 10 just over two and a half to  play in the third  Zim fancy some deee-lite bribes at dumb  it's gonna cross it over here with the  left hand left ends his strong hand but  he goes to his right equally as well  John Lewis got caught leaning and on the  crossover be thought to get in front he  dissed it and relinquished the post  position hundred lob inside  by shipment  when sevens lost to him beat in a crowd  scores anyway and draws the foul  29 there's the pass the catch and the  finish